[Musique]
voici comment s'expriment certaines
plantes sous la terre
dans une obscurité sans fleurs ni
couleur règne pourtant une grande beauté
[Musique]
ses dessins on en compte plus de 1000
sont le travail titanesque d'une
botaniste autrichienne lors kucera
pendant plus de 40 ans avec sa petite
équipe elle a déterré minutieusement des
plantes dans une folle d'environnement
pour en dessiner ensuite le profil
racinaire souvent la partie aérienne les
tiges les feuilles ne représente même
pas 50% de toute la biomasse de la
plante cette collection à la frontière
de l'art et de la science a été
entièrement numérisée et donne à voir
l'étonnante face cachée des plantes